[Music]
oh that's great beautiful jealous when
was the last truly [__] nasty nasty
bad pop girl
[Applause]
the best job in the world
I should be having way more fun
[Music]
I like you
might I ask who are you
it's really like unlock something in me
she's had a tough year the Press has
been brutal
No Angels
it was selfish she took a picture yeah
you could tell about an angle I mean
it's it's kind of it's like a she was on
her [__] knees
pop music is like the ultimate Trojan
Horse
you get people to dance you get people
to sing along come on give me more I
want to be the biggest touring act ever
[Music]
I got a great [__] idea
I haven't seen no [__] like this since
the 90s
brainwasher I promise you there's a new
Jocelyn coming all right
[Music]
hello angels
[Applause]